it's really about hierarchy control we
know better we want to have a society
which works this way an America by
nature works this way
hi I'm Ted baliker with reason TV and
today I'll be speaking with Joel Cochran
kotkin is the distinguished presidential
fellow and urban futures at Chapman
University in his most recent book is
the next hundred million America in 2015
what said the thesis of your book well
basically the book really talks about
the fact that the US has got a very
different demographic trajectory than
the countries that we usually compare
ourselves with most particularly in East
Asia and in Europe and that means we
have a different set of opportunities
and different set of challenges in other
countries and you know I'm basically
optimistic because it's much better to
have a growing younger population than
they shrinking older population optimism
is in short supply these days what would
you say to a pessimist a conservative
who's worried about America's future
pointing to things like runaway spending
immigration well I would say first of
all the main thing is that that that
there's been pushback it seems to me
remarkable that two years after
progressives as they call themselves now
we're seeing a new millennium where they
were going to be dominant and all
virtually unopposed you've had a
enormous shift in opinion back to fairly
conservative positions so in terms of an
immigration although there obviously are
some problems in the immigration policy
immigration is a vote for America people
coming here they're choosing to come
here they're going through tremendous
obstacles to get here and they replenish
our society and we've done a reasonably
good job of integrating them what would
you say to a liberal who's concerned
about the future of America perhaps
worried about environmental problems
sprawl things like that well I mean
first of all I think that the the the
fact the matter is Americans are
environmentally minded I think we are
seeing reductions in how much energy we
use I think the market mechanism will
work extraordinarily well to get people
to buy smaller cars or insulate their
homes I think that's the best mechanism
we have and I think the younger
generation of Americans are very
environmentally conscious is there may
be one or two American cities out there
today that you think kind of represent
what America will look like in 2050 well
I think there's gonna be cities that I
think are gonna be
more important than they are today
Dallas and Houston among the mega cities
I think are gonna be more important but
there's a whole series of cities in the
middle of the country Kansas City Omaha
Fargo Sioux Falls Des Moines all of
which I think have reasonably good
trajectories and you write a lot about
this to that but the migration to
flyover country can you as people I
think a lot of people would you know
they look kind of quizzically at you if
you say Omaha what do you mean by that
well in what you're seeing and you're
already seeing is that is the that
places like Omaha or even Kentucky where
I was recently now have net in migration
these were places that were hemorrhaging
people for 20 30 40 50 years in some
cases a hundred years and now I actually
are attracting people from the outside
as you get a hundred million more people
the natural processes that the places
that are already big will get bigger
more crowded more congested more
expensive and that the next generation
will look for other places to to live
what they consider to be American
middle-class standard of living so let's
let's look at some of the broad strokes
of your book what will America look like
in 2050 America will be a very diverse
country but it will be diverse in its
diversity other words I don't believe
that we're going to have as some
conservatives believe in some
progressive so these these very unmelted
groups of Hispanics who only speak
Spanish or Chinese who only speak
Chinese what you're gonna see is a lot
of blending tremendous growth in the
mixed-race population and an American
culture that will be very very different
than the one today I was in Louisville
recently and I ran into a band that that
was called um apple latina and it was a
blending of Appalachian music with Latin
music and I think we're gonna see a lot
more of that and I think that's gonna
make America a very exciting place in
the next 20 30 years and beyond the
welcoming of immigrants what else do you
see is is on America's side well I think
there's several do one is then we're
going to big thing that we have which is
part of flyover country had enormous
natural resources we're the agricultural
superpower of the world
you know food is going to be a huge huge
industry in the future because you have
3 billion more people a good part of
that population is going to want better
quality food there's no way that China
in India create high-quality food in the
in the amounts that are necessary in the
next 20-30 years and you you right that
in the future the suburbs will grow in
influence of course that's not what the
planners have in mind a lot of times so
there's tremendous pressure politically
to get people to centralized into cities
the people seem to want the opposite how
is that going to sort itself out I think
that one of the biggest problems that
that that of the planners have is they
are just contemptuous of what human
beings want but the vast majority of the
population wants and I don't think that
works long term and this isn't Europe
that we have a growing population the
group the group we just did a survey
recently Millennials their favorite
places where they want to live as
suburbs with the u.s. immigrants they
want to live in suburbs he said the two
groups are going to shape the future
now you can impose this kind of planning
regime over people's preferences I think
you'll get enormous pushback over time
this is one of the big differences
between Barack Obama and Bill Clinton
and I supported Bill Clinton Bill
Clinton understood that the average
American their goal in life was to have
a nice house and a nice neighborhood
with maybe a little backyard that was
what they wanted and he never never
never looked down on that aspiration and
nobody working for him would go out
there and be against that aspiration the
Obama administration is very different
than white you do a lot of work and job
growth as well and that's a hot topic
these days with the high unemployment
rate what it looks like once again Texas
cities have have dominated right in the
areas that that important job you see
unfortunately different reasons Moscow
on the Potomac what's what's there for
these Washingtonians to learn about
what's going on in Texas well I think
what you need is you need to have a
pro-business attitude and you have to
invest in infrastructure you know the
conservative mantra don't spend money
don't have taxes
that's really not what's happened in
Texas in Texas they've put a lot of
money into basic infrastructure the
formula seems to me to be that the
government proper role is to provide the
infrastructure if you will the highway
for the fort for the economy and then
let the private sector sorta to have the
dominant role in creating jobs and feel
you know figuring out where we should go
next in terms of employment when the
government gets so involved in
everything that every job is is
scrutinized by who works there gender
race carbon emissions after a while you
get to a point where the entrepreneur
says forget about it I'm not going to
deal with it I'm not gonna create those
jumps in and we need those entrepreneurs
to be out there creating jobs and
they're doing it much more in Dallas and
using them they are in New York or Los
Angeles let's talk a little bit about
how people will be working in the future
you say that telecommuting is one thing
that's going to be experiencing a lot of
growth well I'm telecommuting is the
logical solution to the energy problem
it is the predominant way that we can
cut back the amount that people travel
and it has lots of other positive things
and people have more time to be at home
they're more community-based I call in
the book the new localism that's a big
part of the next hundred million
stronger more cohesive communities
whether it's a neighborhood or a in a
city or in a suburban community or a
small town and what I find striking
really striking its environmentalists
and the government papers that talk
about how are we going to reduce our
carbon emissions and energy you just
never use the word telecommuting and
says they use the word rail alive they
use the word rail which is infinitely
less efficient doesn't really work in
many cases because there the problem
with telecommuting it's like the suburbs
it's a big thing but it has no
constituency it has no voice nobody
there's almost nobody out there pushing
for it I live in in this extraordinarily
poorly run city of Los Angeles I have to
pay to work at home I pay a fee so that
I don't drive and I'm eyes on the street
and I spend time with my kids and I ride
my bike for most of my errands and I pay
a fee for doing that but they would give
me an incentive
if I if I went to an office in downtown
Los Angeles that would be good but what
I think people don't like about
telecommuting or suburbs or
neighborhoods having power in cities and
I I live in quite an image of the area I
think the real reason is its control
it's really about hierarchy control we
know better we want to have a society
which works this way in America
by nature works this way